I think that the morning really actually
starts the night before I plan the night
before I know what I'm going to do with
the moment I wake up and then upon
waking up I pretty much just start
getting to work and I have my first four
or six hours of the day dedicated to
moving those things forward the second
thing is I try and decrease the amount
of decisions that I have to make
throughout the day I eat the same thing
every day for breakfast lunch and dinner
the third piece is set an alarm for your
bedtime rather than your wake-up time
it's a tiny little hack and I think
it'll do you a lot of good those are the
things that have actually yielded me
disproportionate returns if I've tried
the Gratitude journals I've tried the
saying things out loud the affirmations
I've tried all of these different things
the things that stuck were the things
that were simple and I think that a lot
of times people who look into all these
productivity hacks look into all these
routines many times use that as a crutch
to feel productive rather than actually
getting work done